so Disney is making some huge moves with
their streaming service that is set to
come out in late 2019 their streaming
service is Disney's way of competing
with Netflix and yesterday we learned a
little bit more about their strategy and
why it's such a good thing for Marvel
fans out there also the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway still continued so if
you'd like to enter be sure to subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your thoughts on the
video and your favorite superhero so
Disney has already come out and said
that their streaming service is going to
be cheaper than Netflix is now it can be
cheaper by $1 or $5 we don't really know
but the reason behind that they said is
because of the variety obviously Disney
streaming service will only have Disney
affiliated movies and shows on it and
along with that will come movies and
shows that will be specifically made for
the streaming service such as the remake
of Lady and the [ __ ]
the Anna Kendrick comedy Noelle and
original TV series such as Monsters Inc
and high school musical and of course
the new live-action Star Wars series
coming from Jon Favreau so a lot of
exciting things coming from the
streaming service but one of the most
exciting things that came from them is
when they talked about the future of
Marvel movies so they talked about how
they're going to release them on the
streaming service after they've been in
the theater so pretty much what they
said is that for Captain Marvel and
Avengers 4 as soon as they go through
their run in the theater so however long
that they air in the theater for as soon
as it's done they're going to go right
to the streaming service so this is huge
because we no longer will have to wait
several months from when a movie is in
the theaters to when it comes out on
digital and DVD this is a game changer
and I think it's a smart move by Disney
because they know that a lot of people
just watch movies on Netflix now so this
is their way of doing their own
streaming service and trying to do it
better giving us instant access to
movies as soon as they leave the
theaters
I'm certainly very excited for this news
because as soon as Avengers four leaves
the theater it'll go right to the
streaming service according to this
report and I'm gonna watch it over and
over and over again so let me know your
thoughts about this news from Disney in
the comments below and again the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway still
continues all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]